ALL RIGHT. THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON. WE'RE HOLDING
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING IN ROOM
112 OF THE CAPITOL. I ASK THAT
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PRESENT THEMSELVES IN ROOM 112
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM.
WE ARE ONE, TWO, THREE. WE ARE
GOOD. MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM. I'M BURKE
HERE. BURKE HERE. WILK PRESENT.
WILK PRESENT. ALAN ASHBY.
CABALLERO. HERE. CABALLERO.
HERE. DURAZO DURAZO HERE. LAIRD
I AM HERE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. LAIRD. HERE. MILO, I AM.
MILO. HERE. ROTH STERN. WAHAB
YOU HAVE A QUORUM. ALRIGHTY. AND
I SEE WE HAVE SENATOR GLAZER
PRESENT. SO, SENATOR GLAZER, YOU
YOU MAY BEGIN. SB 393. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. CHAIR. I HAVE
ABOUT A TWO MINUTE STATEMENT.
OH, I DIDN'T I YOU KNOW WHAT,
SENATOR GLAZER? I'M BRAND NEW AT
THIS JOB, SO I FORGOT TO MENTION
THE RULES. THE RULES ARE AS
FOLLOWS. THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONDUCT THIS HEARING JUST LIKE
WE'VE CONDUCTED ALL THE OTHER
HEARINGS IN THE COURSE OF THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS, WHICH MEANS
THAT THERE WILL BE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES OPPOSED EACH
PRIMARY WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO SPEAK AFTER THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SPEAK. THEN WE WILL TAKE THE
SO-CALLED METOOS. THOSE WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE THEIR NAME, THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION.
AND THEN WE'LL TURN TO
OPPOSITION. OPPOSITION WILL HAVE
EXACTLY THE SAME TIME FRAME.
THEY WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH,
TWO WITNESSES, AND THEN THOSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION, PROVIDING ME TWO
TESTIMONY, MAY PROCEED TO THE
MICROPHONE AND GIVE US THEIR
NAME, THEIR AFFILIATION AND
THEIR POSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION,
WE CAN READ. YOU CAN GO TO OUR
WEBSITE AND YOU'LL FIND
INFORMATION AS TO HOW YOU MIGHT
SUBMIT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
FOR OUR CONSIDERATION. NOW,
SENATOR GLAZER, SB 393, WE'RE
HEARING PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE
29.10 SUB D GO AHEAD. JUST FOR
THE RECORD, I JUST WANT TO SAY
WHAT HAPPENS HERE. Tð WHAT
HAPPENS DOWN HERE TOO. GOT IT.
OKAY. THANK YOU. AND MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THIS BILL ACTUALLY
ORIGINATED OUT OF A PROBLEM IN
MY DISTRICT. AND I'LL EXPLAIN
THAT IN A MOMENT, BUT LET ME SET
THE FOUNDATION FOR IT. THIS BILL
HELPS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS FACING A CEQA LAWSUIT
BROUGHT IN BAD FAITH RECOUP SOME
OF THE COSTS OF THAT LITIGATION.
UNDER EXISTING LAW, A DEFENDANT
IN THIS CASE, THE BUILDER IN A
LAWSUIT THAT IS AGAINST AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT MAY
MOTION THE COURT TO REQUIRE THE
PLAINTIFF, THE ENTITY BRINGING
THE CEQA LAWSUIT FORWARD, TO
POST A BOND OF UP TO $500,000.
IF THE BUILDER SATISFIES THE
FOLLOWING. THE HOUSING PROJECTS
ARE AFFORDABLE. THE COURT
AGREES. THE CEQA LAWSUIT WAS
BROUGHT IN BAD FAITH, AND THE
BUILDER PROVES THE ENTITY
BRINGING THE LAWSUIT FORWARD
WOULD NOT FACE UNDUE ECONOMIC
HARM. THIS LAST REQUIREMENT HAS
BEEN NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR ANY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER TO
MEET, BECAUSE IT'S DIFFICULT TO
FIND ANY ADMISSIBLE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE ENTITY'S FINANCES.
THIS DIFFICULTY IS IN PART
BECAUSE THOSE BRINGING A CEQA
ACTION MAY FILE ANONYMOUSLY OR
SET UP AN ORGANIZATION TO HIDE
THE INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS IDENTITY.
IN MY DISTRICT, A 130 UNIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT HAS
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED BY
LITIGATION AFTER THE COURT
AGREED THAT THE LAWSUIT WAS
BROUGHT IN BAD FAITH AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS WERE
UNSUBSTANTIATED. THE COURT
GRANTED A BOND ONLY AFTER THE
PLAINTIFF ACCIDENTALLY ADMITTED
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR FINANCES,
SHOWING THEY WOULD NOT BE UNDULY
HARMED BY POSTING A BOND, SO
THEY MET THE REQUIREMENT. BUT IN
AN UNUSUAL, UNEXPECTED WAY. ONE
REPORT FOUND THAT THIS CASE WAS
THE ONLY KNOWN ONE WHERE THE
COURT GRANTED THE BUILDER A BOND
DUE TO THE DIFFICULTY TO PROVE
ANYTHING ABOUT THE PLAINTIFF'S
TRUE IDENTITY AND FINANCES, THIS
BILL BALANCES THE SCALE, I
BELIEVE, BY ALLOWING THE ENTITY
BRINGING THE CEQA LAWSUIT
FORWARD TO SUBMIT EVIDENCE TO
THE COURT THAT IT WOULD BE
UNDULY ECONOMICALLY BURDENED IF
IT WERE REQUIRED TO POST A BOND.
THIS BILL THEN DIRECTS THE COURT
TO CONSIDER THAT EVIDENCE, WHEN
MAKING ITS DECISION ON WHETHER
TO GRANT THE BOND AND THE FINAL
AMOUNT. FINALLY, THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE COURT TO FIND A
LAWSUIT. IT HAS, AS MERITLESS.
THE BILL WILL MAKE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS WHOLE WHEN
THEY'RE UNFAIRLY TARGETED. AS WE
EXPLAINED IN THIS CASE, FOR
ILLEGITIMATE ECONOMIC CONCERNS.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
LINDA MADDALENA, WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF EDEN
HOUSING, AND MARINA ESPINOSA,
THE POLICY DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM.
WE ALSO HAVE AN EXPERT IN THE
AUDIENCE, ANDREW SARBIB WITH
COX, CASTLE AND NICHOLSON, WHO
CAN SPECIALIZE, WHO SPECIALIZES
IN LAND USE, CAN ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GLAZER. GO AHEAD. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS LINDA MANDOLINI. I AM
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF EDEN
HOUSING. EDEN IS ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S OLDEST NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS AND WE'VE DEVELOPED
MORE THAN 11,000 UNITS
STATEWIDE. WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH ELECTED OFFICIALS TO WIN
APPROVAL FOR OUR PROJECTS,
ENSURE THEY COMPLY WITH LOCAL
ZONING AND FIT INTO THE
CHARACTER OF THEIR COMMUNITIES.
NONETHELESS, WE'VE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
LAWSUITS AGAINST OUR PROJECTS
FROM ANONYMOUS GROUPS WHOSE
MEMBERS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
DISCLOSE THEIR IDENTITIES, AND
WHOSE LAWSUITS ARE INTENDED TO
DELAY OR DERAIL PROJECTS THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED IN LOCAL HOUSING
ELEMENTS AND SUPPORTED BY LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS. IN THE CASE
OF LIVERMORE. AS SENATOR, GLAZER
NOTED, WE WERE FACED WITH A
DAUNTING SEQUA SUIT BY A
WELL-HEELED OPPONENT WHO WHO
KEPT THEIR IDENTITIES ANONYMOUS.
WE WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO SECURE
THE 520 9.2 BONDS BECAUSE THEY
MADE A MISTAKE IN THEIR OWN
DISCLOSURES, BUT NO OTHER
NONPROFIT THAT WE ARE AWARE OF
HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO THIS. AND IN
THE 40 YEARS OF THE 520 9.2
BOND, WE'RE THE ONLY ONE WHO HAS
EVER GOTTEN ONE. WE'RE SIMPLY
ASKING THAT YOU SHIFT THE BURDEN
OF PROOF TO THE PLAINTIFFS WHO
ARE SUING US, AND GIVE US ONE
MORE SMALL TOOL IN OUR EFFORT TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IF
THIS PLAINTIFF HADN'T SUED US ON
THIS SPURIOUS LAWSUIT, WE WOULD
HAVE 130 FAMILIES LIVING IN THIS
COMMUNITY TODAY. INSTEAD, WE
CONTINUE TO BE HELD UP BY, WELL,
WELL-HEELED LITIGATION. AND SO
WE'RE JUST ASKING YOU TO
CONSIDER GIVING ALL OF US WHO
ARE FIGHTING THE GOOD FIGHT ONE
MORE TOOL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS, PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND SENATORS.
MARINA ESPINOSA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM,
CHC ADVOCATES FOR THE PROTECTION
AND PRESERVATION OF LOW INCOME
HOUSING. AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB 393 EXPANDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES IN HIGH
RESOURCE AREAS LIKE DOWNTOWN
LIVERMORE IS A CRITICAL STRATEGY
FOR AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHERING
FAIR HOUSING. WHILE EXPERIENCES
LIKE THOSE DESCRIBED BY EDEN
HOUSING ARE NOT EXPANSIVE, THEY
ARE NOT UNIQUE, AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THEY HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT ON THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO ADDRESS ITS HOUSING
SHORTAGE. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS CANNOT AFFORD YEARS
OF COSTLY LEGAL BATTLES AND WILL
CONTINUE TO SHY AWAY FROM
PROVIDING THE HOUSING WE NEED IN
HIGH RESOURCE AREAS. SB 393
MAKES A MODEST CHANGE THAT WOULD
PROVIDE SOME PROTECTION TO
HOUSING DEVELOPERS FACING CIVIL
ACTIONS, INCLUDING SEQUEL
LAWSUITS THAT CHALLENGE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS AND
BAD FAITH. BY SHIFTING THE
BURDEN TO PROVE THE PLAINTIFFS
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP FROM THE
DEFENDANT ONTO THE PLAINTIFF, WE
HOPE THIS CHANGE IN LAW WILL
DETER FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS WHOSE
SOLE GOAL IS TO STOP AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. FOR THESE REASONS, I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS WHO WISH TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GIVE US
YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION. FOR MANY YEARS,
WITH LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF SPUR, HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE? CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JORDAN
CARVAJAL, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, LET'S NOW TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO SB 393, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. SEEING NO ONE COMING
FORWARD, LET'S COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. SENATOR CABALLERO
WELL, LET ME JUST SAY THAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS BILL. THE
BIGGER ISSUE IS WE'VE GOT TO
HAVE SECRET REFORM. WE JUST WE
GOT TO REFORM IT. EVERY SINGLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT IN MY
REGION WAS, HAD A EITHER A
THREAT OF LITIGATION OR
LITIGATION OVER SEQUA. WE
WOULDN'T HAVE BUILT ANY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IF WE HAD,
YOU KNOW, LISTENED TO THEM. AND
SO THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM. AND I
THINK THIS IS A REALLY, MEASURED
SOLUTION TO TRYING TO GET AROUND
THE ISSUE OF PUT UP MONEY OR
SHUT UP IF YOU'RE GOING TO RUN
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS AND THERE'S
NO BASIS UPON WHICH A COURT CAN
FIND IN YOUR FAVOR, YOU SHOULD
HAVE TO PUT UP MONEY. SO I I'LL
MAKE THE MOTION WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. ALRIGHTY. THANK
YOU. SENATOR WAHAB. THANK YOU. I
JUST WANT TO, ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT MY COLLEAGUE HAS
MADE. I ALSO APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING IN HOUSING THAT'S
LARGELY IN MY BACKYARD, AND I
AGREE THAT EVEN THE THREAT OF A
LAWSUIT, IT STALLS PRODUCTION
AND MUCH MORE UNNECESSARILY, AND
WE NEED TO DEVELOP MORE HOUSING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHER COMMENTS. QUESTIONS,
SENATOR NIELLO. THANK YOU. MR.
CHAIR. AS A COAUTHOR OF THE
BILL, WHAT THEY SAID. ALL RIGHT.
OTHER SENATOR, SENATOR ROSSO,
DID YOU WANT TO COMMENT? WELL, I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE ZEROING
IN ON A SPECIFIC WAY IN WHICH WE
CAN CHANGE THIS TO BE ABLE TO
GIVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS, AS SHE SAID, THE
WITNESS SAID, A REAL
OPPORTUNITY. SO SOMETIMES WE
COME AT SEQUIN, ALL THE PROBLEMS
WITH, YOU KNOW, TRYING TO SAY
THE WHOLE THING IS NO GOOD.
PARTS OF IT ARE. BUT YOU'RE
SOLVING A PARTICULAR ISSUE THAT.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
CABALLERO HAS MOVED THE BILL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GLAZER.
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING IN THIS
SPACE FOR QUITE A NUMBER OF
YEARS, AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
PERSISTENCE, YOUR DEDICATION AND
YOUR CONCERN WITH RESPECT TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, AS WAS ILLUSTRATED BY
THE BY THE WITNESSES. THIS
SIMPLY SHIFTS THE BURDEN TO THE
PLAINTIFF THAT SO THAT THE
PLAINTIFF THEN HAS THE BOTH THE
BURDEN AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMONSTRATE THEIR FINANCIAL
WHEREWITHAL IN TERMS OF POSTING
A BOND, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
JUST TO SAY THANK YOU AND THIS
COULD BE MY FINAL HEARING ON ON
CERTAINLY INVOLVING SEQUA. I
HAVE WORKED HARD IN THIS SPACE.
IT'S BEEN VERY DIFFICULT. I'VE
HAD MANY BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEFEATED, THAT TRIED TO DO
THINGS IN A BIGGER WAY. SO I'VE
KIND OF NOW NARROWED THINGS
WHERE I THINK I CAN CHIP AWAY AT
IT. WE HAVE A REAL LIFE CASE
THAT I THINK MADE THE CASE SO
WELL, THEY LOST, I THINK, A $65
MILLION, 68, $68 MILLION TAX
CREDIT BECAUSE OF THIS DELAY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE YOU HAD ALL YOUR
FINANCE. YOU KNOW HOW DIFFICULT
IT IS TO GET NONPROFIT HOUSING
TO GET TO COME TOGETHER, TO GET
ALL THAT MONEY AND THEN BANG,
BECAUSE THE COURT LOSES $68
MILLION AND THEN NOTHING GETS
BUILT. SO I APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL. AND
I AGREE, OF COURSE, WITH SENATOR
CABALLERO, THAT THERE'S MUCH
MORE TO DO IN THIS SPACE AS WELL
AS SENATOR WAHAB, THIS IS
NARROWLY TAILORED, TAILORED THAT
HOPEFULLY GETS THE SUPPORT OF
YOU AND THE SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR PARTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. IT'S
BEEN A MOTION BY SENATOR
CABALLERO. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FINAL ITEM ONE SB 393. THE
MOTION IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
HAMBURG I HAMBURG I WILK I WILK
I ALLEN I ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO I CABALLERO I DURAZZO.
DURAZZO I LAIRD. LAIRD. I MILO.
MILO. I ROTH. ROTH I STERN.
STERN. I HOPPE. WILL HAVE I 11
TO 0 11 ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GLAZER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE ARE
ADJOURNED.